[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to mike breen the voice of the
knicks he was on the call last night
he probably couldn't sleep last night
i'm guessing after a big win like that
the hall of famer
mike breen on the call with the knicks
over the hawks
brini thanks for joining us can you put
it into words
how big that win was last night
well they won a championship down as you
said
it was uh it was so emotional and the
same thing sunday night game one
and obviously a lot had to do with the
knicks
performance but there's so much more
that went into it
um and it's kind of hard to describe but
um it was like the perfect storm here
you have this loyal
hungry fan base that has been tortured
and heartbroken time and time again not
just with
no playoffs but brutal seasons so
eight years of going through that that's
number one
and i think just as important as the the
pandemic
it's kind of like the family reunion
we've all watched those videos
of families who haven't seen each other
for a year and they
they get to see their mother or father
for the first time or their brothers and
it's so emotional it was like the nick
family reunion at the garden
and and right after the national anthem
of game one sunday
you know this powerful national anthem
one of the great stars of hamilton sang
it
and then the the chants start i was
looking around the arena and our
broadcast location
is in now it's about 20 rows up so we're
in the midst of the fans not on the
court
there were people who were crying and
not just a couple
there were a lot it was such an
emotional thing because it was really
the first
sports gathering uh in new york city
which
like many cities went through you know
horrific times
so the emotions just it got you caught
up i i was emotional myself
but to explain this to somebody and you
you do games
all over the nba in every venue but to
where does this atmosphere rank of of
the different basketball arenas that
you've called games in
well i uh full disclosure uh probably
not the most objective
i grew up in new york i've lived in new
york my whole life i've been a
you know as a knick fan when i was seven
years old captured by clyde and willis
the busher so i might not be the most
objective
but i think in a big event in a big game
there's no better building in sports and
uh again because it has not had that let
me put it this way
over the last several years there's been
games in april
where the knicks are 20 games under 500
they've been eliminated from playoff
consideration for for a month or so and
if it's a two-point game with two
minutes to go
the building sounds like it's game seven
of the finals it's
it's crazy because of this this hungry
desperate fan base that
that experience years ago a great team
and are just they just want a team that
that makes them proud and makes them
feel like they have a chance to win
every night
do you remember a time when free agents
decided that they didn't want to play
for the knicks you know because durant
famously said look i didn't consider
them like basically i don't care about
the
legacy you know of this place but
they haven't gotten they haven't
attracted that that big free agent
why do you think that is because of the
losing
um you know we can talk all we want
about the city and the arena
but if if a team is a is a bad team
and they they have no shot at the
playoffs and in terms of their roster it
doesn't look like it's going to get
better
in time players just don't want to go
there today today's young players
uh they just want to win and you know
some of them
might say oh i i want to be on the
national stage you can be on the
national stage in
any team in any market the country and i
think now it's all about winning and the
emphasis about winning championships and
that's why we're even seeing
you know these star players taking
lesser roles
so they can go to a team that's going to
have a chance to advance to the playoffs
and maybe win them the ring
i did wonder the atmosphere last night
if that resonates with players now
if they see this like now you're
starting to see
or hear what you know you've heard about
in previous
generations here um you know
zion williamson talking about new york
and
you know it almost felt like he was
flirting with the knicks uh earlier this
season and i
i just wonder if if this is a team that
could get out of this first round and go
to another round
and you get more of these games this
atmosphere this environment
can that resonate with younger players
in the nba that wanting to be part of
something
that's special or different yeah i think
it can dan
and and you know last night one of the
biggest cheers of the night
in the middle of the game they put up on
the big screen
a tweet from lebron james talking about
how wow this building's loud the garden
is rocking
the place exploded when it saw that
because another player
another player who declined to come when
he had the opportunity
is talking about what a great atmosphere
it is and and to me that was always
the number one priority for for this
regime
this year was to establish that things
have changed
that now this is a good destination
because you have a chance
not only to play in new york but more
importantly to play on a team that has a
chance to be successful that plays well
together that has an excellent future
and that was number one all this extra
stuff getting into the playoffs getting
the fourth seed maybe advancing to the
second round although
we're obviously short of that right now
um
i think that in some ways is secondary
they have now changed
the perception around the league not
just from players but
agents who have a very big say in what
players go in many occasions so i i
think that perception changing is
has been the most important thing for
them the uh
the f you trey uh trey young is balding
um i mean
this is this is the opening round game
against the hawks mike it's not it's not
like
you know the sixers are in town or the
you know you're playing the nets
yeah they the series is tied at once
and i must say again being a new yorker
with all that's happened over the past
year and with the franchise over the
past eight years
it's very easy to get caught up into it
so i i understand that
as for the the the chance not to sound
like the the parental scolding
gray-haired old man but come on let's
we can be better than that um think of
something clever
think of something funny um even
think of something hostile but that one
particular chant
f trae young over and over again and it
was not just a handful of people it was
a lot
i think we can do better than that i was
i was disappointed in that and i don't
know it looks like there's video of
somebody spitting on trey young
uh were you aware of that i saw the
headline i didn't see it wasn't aware of
it until
about a half hour ago and that's you
know same thing with the
russell westbrook i mean spitting and
throwing popcorn are clearly two
different things
um but i i think it's it's something
that just has to be stopped westbrook is
right
and it's up to the arenas and it's up to
the teams to
to make sure if that happens and even
the fans around them to
to to try and stop that thing right away
because it's just
i mean it's it's clearly disgusting when
people do stuff like that
he's mike breen hall of famer by the way
congratulations on that honor
thank you how did you find out about
that
um the initial time was i got a uh
i got a uh an email they tried to call
me i was on a flight
and i got an email um while i was on the
flight i think it was new york to la
so i'm reading the email and you know
something like that brings about so many
memories of so many people that helped
you
so i'm sitting on the plane and of
course now i've got tears in my eyes and
they're streaming down my face and the
guy sitting next to me he's looking at
me like
oh am i sitting next to one of these
clowns
so i wanted to tell him no i'm okay but
i i didn't have the heart to tell him
you should have gotten on the
loudspeaker and just said look i'm
emotional in case you're wondering
uh you know trade tables in the upright
lock position and
i'm a hall of famer yeah i don't know if
that would have worked as well
or i should just just looked at him and
said i just get emotional every time
uh when did when did you uh develop the
bang when did that
come about with your your signature call
uh actually in college when i was a
student at fordham
i broadcast the games on the college
radio station wfub
and i didn't use it on the air i used it
when i went as a fan you know
when i wasn't calling games i was in the
stands rooting on my on my college team
and when a fordham player hit a big shot
i would as a fan scream it out
and i tried it on the air a couple of
times when i was doing college radio
and i didn't like it i didn't think it
was it worked
so i kind of shelved it for a while and
then i started doing some
some tv later on and i felt it work
better and i liked it at the end of
games
when it was a big call because i didn't
feel i had a strong enough voice to
override the crowd
and if you have you know a single
syllable word that
kind of punctuates the the moment and
then get out of the way and let the
crowd take over
that's when i i started using that on a
regular basis and i thought
you know it was a good time at that
point of the game to use a bang-worthy
moment i go back to
steph curry hit a shot in that 2015
oklahoma city from about you know 38
feet
and like it it was a great exclamation
point
without taking away from the play you
added to the play
by just that bang and then you know it
it just
it felt like how did i do by the way
i thought you did very well okay thank
you okay thank you thank you
um yeah sometimes when you go back and
listen to it
i think who's the screaming fool but if
you love the sport
and i do and i've loved basketball since
i was a kid
you so get caught up in the emotion and
that particular play that you speak of
was
that was when he was on that incredible
run the team was like 54 and
five and everything worked together and
and he got hurt earlier in the game they
were down 12 and they still came back
and won it was that
magic carpet ride they were on so you
just you get caught up in the moment
sometimes
could you maybe give me uh patrick
from three you give me a bang or
something i mean is that
probably unprofessional but uh you know
i thought i'd ask
well do you have a basket there do you
have a ball you can shoot
is that possible i do have a hoop here
but you can assume it's going in
i mean it's me you're very cocky with
your game
yes i am yes i am if nobody's guarding
me
i'm uh i'm i'm trey old
i like that yeah i'm i'm gonna make it
damn patrick for three bang okay you
nailed it
i love it it's the first that's a first
quarter yeah well i know and i'm fine
with that
i know i i can't wait for the fourth
quarter and overtime
there uh how close do you think lebron
was to coming to the knicks
i don't think he was close at all i know
the story recently
came out that he wanted um but that
his wife didn't want to now who knows if
that's if that's true or not
but the way i look at it if he really
wanted to come
to new york he'd be there he would have
been there and
uh i don't think it was i don't i i
don't think at that particular time it
was
it was even a possibility yeah i wonder
about that that if his wife didn't want
to go
and uh you know she's probably saying
all right we've been in cleveland we've
been in miami we've been back to
cleveland
now where are we going and she probably
i could understand her saying look let's
just pick a spot where we're going to
stay
so i can raise the family here
yeah it's it's only he knows for sure um
but i didn't think
you know i think he was being kind uh
to saying okay yeah i thought about it
was possibility i really was interested
but i don't think
i don't think there was a chance they
were going to get him we got uh one of
your broadcast partners jeff van gundy
on the show tomorrow
why is he so cranky
he's actually he's actually uh
well i shouldn't say we we haven't
spoken in months
we had an argument a couple months ago
we were able to do it professionally on
the air
um but off the air so if he's got
something going on that makes him cranky
i'm not really certain
why wow i don't wow that that was a marv
albert and answer there that that
the ultimate compliment yes yes that
definitely a more of albert answer
you got uh suns lakers on sunday
do you have that correct okay and then
you got nets celtics you got that
tomorrow night
yes that will be that'll be a hostile
crowd as well
yeah well i don't know if it matters
without jaylen brown there
that's a good point but if if the
celtics don't compete
uh they'll spend the night uh booing
kyrie irving probably
yeah and then sons lakers i don't know
the availability of uh
of chris paul does that have you ever
when's the last time you were surprised
going into a game and you're like this
team has no chance of winning this game
oh it happens all the time i mean that's
the beauty of the nba now does it happen
in playoffs
perhaps not i thought you know what i
was surprised i was really surprised
at the other night game two uh clippers
and mavericks
all right so clippers lose game one at
home all right that happens
but then they come back and beaten like
that
that that was a surprise because this is
a clipper team that their whole season
is geared toward getting back into
playoffs and redemption from
from the collapse last year and for them
to have that
um it shows number one how there's
something still not right there
and number two that luca doncic is going
to be one of the all-time greats well
you're a hall of famer so
he'll eventually join you in the hall of
fame i guess mike is that what you're
saying
was that a roundabout way of me coming
wow that
is self-serving
i can't well i can't wait to get on a
plane now and and go over the
loudspeaker yes
well no just have the flight attendant
just say you know and we would like to
uh let everybody know we have a hall of
famer on the flight he's uh mike breen
he's
seated in 2a uh don't don't come up to
him he's crying right now but
uh
this do you get like as you get older i
mean
um do you get more emotional as you get
older oh yeah i'm a mess but you cry at
commercials
yes yeah okay so we're kindred spirits
oh no it's embarrassing like my son got
married a couple of weeks ago
i i was holding on to the back of my
wife's shoulders crying into her hair
trying to muffle the sound as my son
came down
you think dick for meal is an emotional
mess like i
i i crush him people i was making the
wedding party cry it's like it was just
horrible horrible i'm i'm heaving you
know when you cry and it's like
my son's getting married i should be
happy i'm crying
i got three daughters mike that i gotta
walk down the aisle there's no way i can
do it
oh forget it forget my worst one again
was i
i shouldn't say this again it was on a
plane
i'm trying to watch a movie and i pick
because
i remember this movie i enjoyed with my
kids finding nemo
is one of the great adult movies
and as the movie is near the end and
it's this wonderful father-son
relationship
i'm crying on the plane watching finding
yeah and there's nothing wrong with that
there's there's no shame in that but
you're only
by yourself you're more by yourself
there i i'm on display
god i i i i want my daughters to get
married but i don't want them to get
married just because i don't want to cry
well i wanted to i'm proud of you dan
thank you mike thank you mike
uh safe travels and uh good luck on the
plane
[Laughter]
thank you bang bang
curry from 38 bang yeah i'll work on
that
i'll work on that thank you mike that's
uh the hall of famer mike breen
he uh will be on the call net celtics
tomorrow night
and then suns lakers on sunday afternoon